Puccini jetsam a young kid runs an
organic chemistry lab at Bangkok's main
university she's won numerous awards and
is one of the few women in Thailand to
have made it to the top in research to
get there she's had to face some
prejudice about the role of women in
this traditional society I did have to
look intellectual because otherwise they
will say we we used our beauty or we use
our sweetness to finish the work so it's
not like that but I feel that I have to
to prove myself for them some of my male
colleagues but Anita designs organic
materials to improve the efficiency of
solar cells she supervises at those and
graduate students most of them young
women plenty of women choose to study
chemistry she says but pursuing a career
in research is difficult because of
societal expectations and the pressures
of family life my people is a little bit
more especially for the one hanging
family
so that we have some expectation from
people around according to our whole
tradition that the Chinese have to take
care of the house
that hold us up a little bit in visiting
if you give up Etsy but Anita has
watched some of her classmates drop out
of research her friend
PACA sip left the lab to become a
full-time senator doesn't have children
at 38 she lives with her parents which
is common in Thailand
their home is conveniently close to the
University they are clearly very proud
of her but Anita says that the two main
ingredients for success are supportive
family and the huge dose of
determination
her mother agrees that the university
pasinetta is focused on finding
applications for her compound the aim of
her research is to develop thin flexible
solar cells now if I can make it
here we go the little waterworks one day
they could be stuck in a bag and used to
charge a mobile phone or rolled out on a
roof to provide electricity and maybe
also one day patch Anita and others like
her will inspire a change in attitudes
towards women and science in Thailand
you